[Music]
when I talk with people it almost seems
like there's a little bit of a rivalry
between the movies tangled and frozen
I guess everyone just has their cg
princess movie that they connect with
more
well now you can add Moana into the mix
because I know so many folks that just
fell in love with this movie I guess it
makes sense you have one that takes
place in an average fairy tale
environment another one that takes place
in a winter environment and now you have
one that takes place in a very warm
environment each one has a location that
people want to escape to but Moana has a
lot more going for it outside of justice
location our main lead is the daughter
of an island chief who's trying to train
for when she becomes chief big surprise
though her heart yearns for more and she
wants to go exploring but the people
very much don't want to leave because
they're afraid of the dangers out there
when she discovers in the past that her
people were explorers she decides to set
out on her own to see what she can
discover well that and hopefully save
the world you see a powerful force has
been corrupted and is turning everything
black and dead one of the only
salvations which also happens to be the
cause of all of this is Maui played by
the rock he apparently stole something
from this powerful force and that's
what's setting all this terribleness in
motion Moana of course meets up with
Maui and they're about as opposite they
can be her being very tiny and hopeful
and him being very big and full of
himself together they come across all
sorts of weird creatures bizarre
environments and eventually the evil
force to try and stop it so truth be
told I didn't quite connect with this
movie like I do with tangled and frozen
but it's still a very enjoyable movie
the animation is phenomenal the
environment looks beautiful
a lot of the creatures especially the
villain at the end just look amazing and
on top of that yeah some really hummable
songs that aren't gonna leave your head
anytime soon I guess the issues I have
is that while there are a lot of Disney
cliches that some people are okay with I
find there some that people start to get
tired of as well and don't get me wrong
tangled and frozen are filled with
Disney cliches they're just the Disney
cliches I don't mind as much I get when
people say they're sick of the dead
parrot they're sick of the curses
they're sick of castles and pretty
dresses and falling in love with
handsome guys I understand that
for me they're not quite as bad because
there's so many other cool creative
things in it Moana is the same way with
a lot of people there's so much good
stuff that people connect with that they
really overlook the other cliches for me
though these cliches I'm just done with
the main character that has to stay one
spot but once de journee wants to listen
to her heart the wise parent or
grandparent that passes away yet comes
back as a ghost at the end to give some
sound advice the cute little comic
relief that doesn't talk or should I say
one and a half comic relief's there's
this pig that kind of disappears why was
it even in the movie the comedy as well
it's okay but it just didn't make me
laugh as much as tangled or frozen the
rock especially I was really ready to
laugh a lot at and yeah I got a few
chuckles he was charming enough but
there was nothing I was really laughing
that hard at apart from his song you're
welcome it also really bothers me that
pretty much everything in this movie is
his fault and at the end all he does is
just kind of bow his head and kick his
heel and say I'm sorry and that like
excuses everything you didn't even
really look like he meant it and yet
somehow he gets a big reward out of all
this even the big transformation that
happens at the end well done beautifully
I would have liked a little bit more
focus on I would have liked to have seen
more what this creature was like before
it was turned into this dark terrible
thing and what changes it back I guess I
feel like all the ingredients are there
and they mix well just not great I
wanted to be more invested I wanted to
laugh harder I wanted to really be
sucked into the drama
maybe the familiarities that they have
are just a little too familiar for me
but with that said like a lot of their
other modern fairy tales they kind of
make a few changes to that are very
welcomed
for example Moana Maui don't get
together they're not even romantically
interested in each other that's
refreshing because I'm watching these
two I'm thinking they work fine off each
other if they're gonna have them
suddenly kiss at the end it wouldn't
make any sense and they don't do that
I guess is something that they advertise
a lot that Malanda is technically not a
princess I'm not
I'm the daughter of the chief I don't
know that's not gonna stop her for being
in all the princess lineups
I still don't 100% know how Mulan got in
there but like I said before I can't act
like the other Disney movies I like
don't rely on a lot of familiar cliches
they're just cliches they don't bother
me that much for others these are
cliches that maybe drive them nuts and
the cliches in this film maybe don't for
me I would have liked a few more
surprises and changes in such a familiar
story but for a lot of people these are
the elements they really like in a lot
of Disney movies and I totally get that
so yeah it's a good flick I can't in any
way say it's bad just sometimes a little
standard but like I said you've come to
expect that with Disney films and maybe
this kind of standard you'll like more
than the other kind of standards I'd
definitely say check it out because the
people that like it really seem to like
it
there's just some kind of really strong
connection to the changes they make but
the stuff they keep the same I guess
it's a perfect combination of the
familiarity they love but the updates
they want to so how do you find it okay
or absolutely fall in love with it it's
an adventure worth setting sail to
experience
[Music]
you